you
[Music]
g'day everybody last year i was empty
our studio conference as well and the
several questions have been addressed
about tidy time-series analysis during
the conference especially forecasting
with tidy objects so today I'm going to
present a solution to that so I want to
talk about a streamlined workflow for
time series under the tidy versa
framework using two packages I introduce
you three big ideas behind those two
packages so they're at Sybil Mabel and
fable and how they link together I hope
to explain them concretely with date her
stories so I believe this diagram isn't
foreign to you this is a tiny verse
modem and each module here is powered by
one of the tiny verse packages and the
tiny verse plays seamlessly with each
other and one of the fundamental reason
is they all share the same underlying
data structure which is data frame or a
table so the data is actually placed in
the center of the diagram but why we
cannot bring this work flow easily into
time series so because the current time
series object in our a model focused by
saying more oh I mean it not only
includes statistical models but also
forecasting decomposition
autocorrelation function and other time
series tools and all the methods of
functions expect matrices as inputs but
the data arrives in the right beginning
of this process it rarely comes into the
matrix form and we have to write so much
and whole code to get the data into a
time series model ready object it is a
pain because of the temporal because of
mismatch between temporal data and time
series models so we hope to change that
so some new trios are provided to
streamline this workflow and make time
series analysis a bit easier more fun
and more intuitive so the table package
will focus on the tidy and truth
Meishan part the fable package will two
times through is forecasting and the
visualization is done with ggplot2 and
its extensions so to make this workflow
works they are going to share the same
underlying data structure which is a new
data abstraction for time series and we
call it
Sybil so similar is a time series table
and if you know TS is a native object to
represent time series in R so this is
where the named Sybil comes from so now
we are going to have some fun with the
open dataset so this data set is about
residential electricity consumption in
Australia so it's a table with 46
million observations and 8 variables so
the column custom ID includes unique
identifiers for each household thousands
of households in this dataset and a
rating date/time gives the timestamps
when the rating is recorded every 30
minutes general supply is a variable
that we are interested in forecasting
and there are some other measurements in
the table as well so first how are we
going to turn this data into a Sybil so
what makes x 3 special or different from
a normal data frame because it has its
own semantics so the first one is
obviously the index variable that
represents time so in this case it's
reading date/time and Sybil supports a
wide range of time classes so for
numerix to take time to nano time so the
second component is what we call key and
the identifying variables that define
series or entities over time for this
example each household is a series and
the key verbal is customer ID it also
includes multiple variables in the key
so basically index defines the time and
the key defines the series
so the key together with index uniquely
identifies each observation in at Sybil
by 3 means each
customer has to have unique time stamps
and for this data yes they are
so now we have at Sybil so Tebow gives a
very nice printing method and Sybil is
going to enhance that by ending
contextual information so now we have a
table with data dimensions and it's
recognized thirty minutes interval and
the times were associated with the index
so here we have UTC but you might have
liked time zones with daylight savings
for example and Sybil will respect any
time zone in your data
so the key variable is reported with a
number of the series so we have two
thousand nine hundred twenty four
customers in this big table and we also
got some time caps in this data so they
are implicit missing values since
ggplot2 isn't aware of those gaps it
always just a straight line between data
segments if you use geom line and symbol
comes with a very handy function called
filled gaps so it fills in those gaps by
an with an A by default or you can do by
values or functions so those lines can
be removed from the plot easily with
fill gaps so except for few gaps
Simo provides other three verbs to
handle implicit missing menus and they
also fixed by caps so nearly 20% of the
customers have time gaps and output
shown here you can see the last two
customers with gaps so almost all the
model functions require complete time
series so it's a good practice to look
and and filling those gaps in the first
place so zero works nicely with DES
plier and tyria verbs a new end verb you
will use quite often is indexed by so
it's similar to group by preparing
grouping structure but only groups the
index so combined with summarize the
data can be aggregated to any high level
time resolutions so for example I want
to work with
our data instead of 30 minutes now Youth
floor date or selling date a runt age
from the loopy tech package of index
variable inside index pine followed by a
summarize so I get only average
electricity usage across all the
households so the result is going to be
a single time series and one hour
interval and the key is implicit
so another chunk of operations for time
series is definitely rolling window and
it not only does it eration over each
element like what per map does but also
needs to roam so what I'm going to do is
to wake up this cat and let her roll so
actually there are three different types
of rolling operations so sliding Tarling
and stretching so it's just like her
slide takes wine puts its light to
texturing boots and peace light for
multiples so if you have a data frame to
roll by observations you need to use
peace light and for the purpose of type
stability they're going to return a list
and other variants include like integers
characters mode codes etc so in a recent
version I've ended the parallel support
they are all prefixed with future by
using the fur package by Davis as a
back-end so if doing some rolling
regressions so it's hot it's nice to
save some time by rolling them in
parallel and you can put an arbitrary
function through those rolling windows
so a single example is rolling average
it uses Prolog syntax so you can call a
function name or an anonymous function
using children I specify the window size
tribute 24 so basically one day and is
rolling forward from left to right if
you want to move in an opposite
direction just to change the window size
to be negative so those three rolling
windows as you can see result different
averages
a more advanced example but extremely
useful is rolling forecasts so I defined
a custom function called expand forecast
and also enable parallel processing by
using future P stretch it's never been
that easy to do expanding forecasting
are so a nice thing about functional
programming is we can focus on writing
expressions instead of writing on lung
for loop statement so what sort of code
goes into the expand forecast and this
question brings us to the next part of
the presentation
tidy forecasting so how many of you have
used the forecast package before quite a
lot thank you so the favor is a tidy
replacement of the forecast package so
while it quite fable first it makes
forecasting tables second a fable is
like a forecast it's never true but it
tells you something useful so let's take
a look at the data in the first 30 days
of January so each facet gives a daily
snapshot of hourly electricity demand
and the pig is elect afternoon is driven
by the use of air conditioning and
generate in the summertime in Australia
you can see some tastes have much higher
usage carved by red because they are
very hot days with maximum temperature
greater than 32 degrees and I'm going to
use this subset to forecast the demand
one day ahead and a holder teacher of
January 31 is the test set so let's
model the data so I construct two models
for the energy consumption with a modal
verb and the first model I built is a
naive model as a benchmark so the lining
method simply uses the observed values
from yesterday as forecasts and such
second model is ETS exponential
smoothing which can be thought of as a
weighted average of the past venules
and ETS is also short for era trend and
seasonality so the model function uses a
formula interface so on the left hand
side we specify the average supply as a
response variable and on the right hand
side we can put some specials related to
the message so I've specified the naive
function to use the 24 values from
yesterday instead of the value from the
previous hour and if we don't specify
the right hand side like 80s so it will
do automatic model selections by picking
up the best model for you
so now we have a Mabel back so a Mabel
is a model table that contains model
objects so it's cell shows a succinct
model representation saying I have a
seasonal noggin model and that it yes
with three selected components so models
are reduced the form of the teacher so
the model function is an analogue of
summarized because they use the same
semantics and the model function also
reduces the data down to a singles
summary but it happens to be a model
object of that summary so in order to
look at like preempt estimates
information criteria or residuals from
model objects with just use the familiar
blue functions tidy clothes and augment
by applying the tidy function on the
mabel we get the parameter estimates for
the models with butte so we've got a
bunch of parameters for ets like alpha
beta and I know those are pouring
parameters so it's time to forecast we
pipe the Mabel into the forecast
function and we're doing a one-day ahead
forecast equivalent 24 steps ahead and
it supports human friendly input so we
can read more naturally like forecasting
with one day horizon it's convenient
because we no longer need to mentally
compute how many hours minutes seconds
day but you can still to H equal to 24
and we're down with forecasts we have a
forecasting table which is a fable so
it's a special table which includes the
future predictions it's not only to see
the point forecasts but also an
underlying prediction distribution that
involves uncertainty because we are
forecasters not fortune tailors USA the
normal distribution with its mean and
standard deviation in the last column
dot distribution and this is one of my
favorite features about fable reporting
distribution forecasts so you are able
to produce any level of prediction
interval you like and will see the
forecast more clearly with plots using G
own forecasts so the naive method
repeats yesterday's pattern but eighty
and ninety five predictions intervals
are quite large and some even goes below
zero so how about in two years so the
idiots nicely captures the daily trend
and produces a much narrower prediction
interval and which model performs better
so use an accuracy function to compare
the predictions with the test set that
are held before
salukis accuracy measures it has the
slightly better than the naive in terms
of root mean squared error but they all
tend to give underestimated predictions
and the black line in the plot is actual
data so looks like it's another hot day
in January if you have weather
information like temperatures we can
include them to improve the forecasts
but need to use a different model that
allows for exhorting us regressors for
example ARIMA model so far i've showed
all the steps from model building model
assessments for just one time series
would be any different
if we have multiple time series in the
table no because models are
fundamentally scalable so zero has a
modern reinvention of time series it
designs for hosting many time series
together especially the series have
already predefined
when we created the Sybil and we are
obviously interested in forecasting
for each household here so I removed
some troublesome series ended up with a
thousand four hundred eighty households
so no extra steps needed for forecasting
and scale just as what we did before we
can't directly type them into the model
function it will fit an ETS model for
each customer and once and then happy
forecast they also take a log
transformation of the response variable
to ensure that I get positive forecasts
back and the forecast function will take
care of the back transformation for you
Sika say a thousand four hundred eighty
models have been faded in the Mable and
the key variable is always a key to
refer to a series across civil Mable and
fable models are scalable but
realization is not so just applaud for
customers with your forecasts here and
the individual level lots of noise
producing much larger prediction
interval as well so I'm sure the
proportion of what Sybil and fable can
do we've got decomposition simulation
based on motivates interpolation of
missing values and model supports for
streaming data so please check them out
so it's a joint word with die crook Rob
Hyman and Mitch o-haru out I need to
mention that Sybil isn't run but Faber
is on github at the moment and they all
belong to tidy words talk those are the
useful links through those packages my
slides and the source code behind the
slides that's all from me thank you
thank you so much you know we have time
for a couple of questions and we have
throwable mics real thing around so just
raise your hand okay
I'm wondering if any of these tools are
well-suited to a regular time series and
not yet okay but civil support irregular
data structure hi I was wondering if
this supports hierarchical time series
reconciliation yes we're considering
that probably our second half of this
year what is the level of maturity of
the package with compare that the models
that available today in the forecast
package so it's sort of a nice thing to
go to crown-like sometime in March or
April and if like to replace the whole
forecast package would be like the end
of this year I think oh I noticed that
there's a rival Tibble time package and
I'm learning what the difference between
civil and table time is and so so
basically it is that true time series
structures and we've got a cup of things
in common
so first both are built on top of Tebow
and second both declared index verbal
but for civil we require the key as well
and also does the check so needs to be
distinctive observations so this makes
SIBO is different from civil time and
also the function like interface are
also different to answer your question
I think we have time for one more
question
I love these things so kind of a shoot
off of the last question or do you have
any plans to incorporate the ability to
specify time windows using shorthand
like XTS does or like tipple time does
uh yes I do have the functions it's
called a few our future underscore index
so it does support the shorthand just I
just to check the documentation please
[Music]